on me l'imposé bouger ton meilleur
projet est longue à la mode du caramel
elle ne me semble pas être rien mais ne
comble pas belle mais qu'on peut pas
parce que c'est une chaîne qui est
complètement brand que c'est vrai on a
imposé il ya six ans non à la six ans
elle ce même pas son âge forcément elle
pense pas schiphol fait rien alors il
est où le jeu met encore je sais pas la
chine de mes rêves elle est folle ayant
lutté ramadier était un petit peu
déphasé je vous avais dit qu'elle avait
un pois chiche dans la tête ces
prospectives
elle a toujours été comme ça même tout
petit câlin peu d'espoir cannell pour la
séduire
j'ai tout essayé oui je suis pro garde
voilà you hear vos jours c'est le sud où
le ch a choisi tu voulais ce petit bout
flèche à tamedia si tu viens
cannell alors elle a tous les défauts
elle et voleuse
elle ouvre les portes l abîme tout alors
on a mis les les
un truc là pour veiller porte à l'envers
elle a appris à les voir s'en servir à
l'envers mais c'est fou écoute là bien
couché coucher coucher coucher quand on
met tout sur la table elle le vol est
oui c'est fou hein écoute tous on va on
va faire deux ou trois plans coffre juin
doberman comme ça qu'ils étaient branco
si et je les données pendant un mois
j'aimerais sûr c'est belmondo mais
donner l'adresse mail vas-y tabet on va
donc une raison on dresse toutes les
bêtes et bien je vous jure je raconte
pas d'histoires un jus pas excessive le
dresseur ma demande à guy larmes dans
les yeux de la reprendre
il n'en pouvait plus et pocho leur
disais je vais avoir un battable avoirs
à fiat et jean pas du tout elle est
idiote makan elle qui lui donne à manger
c'est vous ou laissez-vous ce soin à
d'autres annonces et françoise qui s'en
occupe c'est ma nièce issue voilà alors
quand même je pense qu'à cette année ça
m'attriste rabat cette chaîne predator
en soit il est certain que quand
françoise n'est pas là c'est vrai
qu'elles tendent d'ailleurs cannelle
repos lui reprocher ça l'était perdu
tendre elle pleure ça voudra pas atteint
et énervé comme ça garde caennaise
à lui assis là gentil j'ai un petit
voile alors là on obtient tout d'elle
tout en voyant le même succès mais xénon
jeunet mic colère voilà merde c'est
vraiment très slave vous allaitez ventes
attendues aux oreilles dressées à vis tu
faire quant à la grèce ses mémoires
c'est kamel cannelle kallel canal tous
dans la maison on adore répète alors au
début dès le début on l'a fait vraiment
presque deux pièces cuisine salle de
bain 1 entrée choisey remarquer ya
seulement alors j'ai mis une couverture
élevée pas rester dehors
c'est quand même ça chien de garde j'ai
une maison j'ai un grand jardin quand
même ce chien de garde
elle est rentrée alors qui peut alors
lui a remis un panier intérieur après le
verre sortir elle montre la bibliothèque
elle au bout de trois minutes elle se
lève
elle arrache la porte à lui ressortir
non elle n'est pas possible elle est pas
parce qu elle jalouse de vous nous ne
nous n'est même pas particulièrement je
crois qu'à part les enfants ça va bien
avec les enfants même personne
particulièrement pense pas à tout ça par
tmc sucre et gourmand à vous dit qu'elle
a tous les défauts mathieu parce qu'elle
manque quelquefois les faces du facteur
le terrain
par contre elle fait la faute aux
vagabonds elle a aucun sens des nuances
je suis en train de la noircir pauvres
bêtes pauvre cannelle on adore toutes
façons à dos mais c'est notre faute tout
ça on n'est pas fait du tout pour avoir
des bêtes
en effet pour les aimais bien sûr mais
ya pas que ça en eux on ne sait pas
c'est pas tout de donner la patte et de
la caresser faut savoir aussi se faire
obéir et la chaîne n'en serait que mieux
elle en serait plus équilibrée
certainement c'est pas elle qui est
fautif c'est nous lui a eu avec ses
papilles et de faire des fleurs cela
vous agace
bien sûr ça n'amuse personne c'est
encore elle nous faisait intelligemment
mais aussi elle le fait bêtement
si j'ai deux mille mètres carrés c'est
pas suffisant et j'ai vu une petite
barrière pour caler son coin où elle
puisse quand même et puis que mon jardin
soit un peu protégés non non non mais
preuve des ventes aux usa alors là je
n'ai même plus joli jardin
elle m'a foutu toutes mes fleurs en
l'air mais tous elle piétine tout j'ai
eu presque pas de tulipes cette année à
cause d'elle alors parce qu'elle saute
par dessus la barrière elle a appris
aussi à sauter par dessus la barrière
voilà les quelques semaines elle est
tellement turbulente elle est tellement
instable que elle pourrait toujours ait
pu avoir un chien j'ai pas eu cette
chance un chien couché se réfugier dans
le décor même j'aurais pu poser ma main
délicatement sur sa tête elle aurait
frémiot voyeuse mans rien rien elle
reverserait tout [ __ ] en l'air mon
manuscrit alors châu ailleurs ça fout
dehors de quelle manière vous adorez
s'il ou elle
ça dépend de mon humeur ça dépend du
temps quand je suis dehors que je prends
un bain de soleil par exemple qu'elle
vient un soleil à poil en général et
qu'elle va me sauter sur le ventre alors
là je là vraiment je la rabroue très
brutalement quelquefois j'aimerais
tellement envie c'est vrai dans son jeu
j'aurais très envie d'être tendre avec
cannelle mais elle ne me le permet pas
mais c'était de ma faute
viens vite fruits vous est-il arrivé de
vous bêtifier en utilisant des mots tels
que baballe susucre oui par dérision
pour amuser les enfants
j'ai jamais bêtifier avec les enfants et
ils ont un sens très aigu de l'humour et
du ridicule et ça je le fais pour les
faire et il arrivait que kamel soit la
seule à vous attendre à vous accueillir
ce soir
oui elle assène qu'est ce que vous
ressentez en ce moment la cbat j'aime
bien
j'aime bien parce que j'aime bien
d'abord parce que je ne suis pas seule
dans la vie mais j'aime bien ce moment
de solitude avec les bêtes c'est pour ça
que j'aurais tellement aimé avoir des
bêtes chaque fois un peu plus le plus
simple